we're in the museum in the field de
Janeiro and I've come here to look at a
periodic table but I've discovered
something else that's really exciting
some of you may know that I'm obsessed
with plastic bottles I have a big
collection of them in my office and I
came here and discovered they're making
molecular models with them look at this
one over here it's all made out of
plastic bottles and yellow plastic pipe
and I think it's really clever and let
me show you how they do it because you
could do it at home or in your school
and make huge models like this
so what they have done is they have
taken the tops of plastic bottles and
cap them off you see just this part here
and then they have taken several of them
and showing them together to make atoms
here you can see an atom of carbon which
is tetrahedral and then they've just
used the top of the bottle to make a
hydrogen atom and they can take pieces
of plastic pipe cheap pipe that you can
buy in shops so you can screw them
together and make bonds and this one
they painted red and so suddenly out of
plastic bottles you can make fantastic
molecular models I've always wanted a
big molecular model and now here it is
made out of plastic bottles I really
like this because it's a very clever use
of bottles something that everybody has
something that people throw away and
also it's very difficult to get big
models they're very expensive and
they're not what you want the colors are
wrong and here you can make them
yourself and also I really like the
plastic that this is made of PE T
because I do research on terephthalic
acid the molecule that goes into these
bottles so it combines my research my
interest in chemistry and it's just fun
so go and make some yourself so here
I've discovered something else that's
good because you probably know that
molecules are not rigid they vibrate and
here you can show the vibrations it's
really good I wish I could take some of
these back to England but I'll have to
make them myself
you